qu'est devenu benjamin des queer à vous
rappeler de benjamin je croise tout le
temps ça vous le croisez beaucoup 1 où
ça va prendre un peu la vérité il est il
est serveur très souvent dans le
quartier où j'habite
alors c'est con parce que c'est vrai que
il est chef indien dans un restaurant de
grillades
voilà mais c'est vrai il est chef indien
indien parce que c'est là c'est
l'emblème à cette adresse david thébault
jalava absolument il faut des serviettes
et à il faut des bergues et aux barbes
qui changent il faut tout il est temps
pour soi parce que non mais il est
toujours aussi beau il est il est
charmant il est très gentil il est très
bon dans les couilles absolument très
bon en boîte de nuit très près bon plein
de choses et bat très bien et benjamin
des queer et a vécu ce soir le maire
[Applaudissements]
merci merci merci
franchement je suis très heureux c'est
pas ça passe ou ça casse les couilles tu
sais que j'adorais cette émission en
2004 et l'examen mais je trouve que tu
as un talent exceptionnel c'est vrai
quand on m'a dit qu'on va être recevoir
j'étais très heureux parce que je trouve
qu'un naturel je trouve que tu écris je
te jure et je crée une écriture c'est
quoi je vais te dire je regrette de ne
pas avoir hacké producteur de télé et
animateur de télé à l'époque pour je
t'aurais produit ce que je te remercie
beaucoup
je suis très content j'étais fan de toi
dis moi ce que tu ce que tu fais alors
c'est moi le regard et dans sa région
j'ai entendu qu'il allait aller petit
avec d'autres coquinou comme s'ils
avaient rien et un sort en boîte de nuit
on avait un petit peu rigoler tout ça et
on était vraiment passé à ça se souvient
de de rentrer ensemble
oui très beau des gaules est quand même
bien la ville est magnifique
j'hésite entre deux jambes at elle été
laissée vide à la gare ils voient tous
les travées sont ces six ans sarah
n'essayez pas de casser des couples
jamais alors raconte nous parce qu'il ya
eu des coups hier sur tf1 avait été
repérée comment moi j'avais fait le
casting d'accord pour courir à la base
c'est un casting que j'ai accompagné un
mes meilleurs potes de l'époque puisque
l'option se parlent plus oui et lui
c'est pour le faire le tour de tout le
grooming donc coiffeurs maquilleurs et c
est le directeur de casting et à l'oeil
nu mais tu es sûr que tu veux pas faire
que voilà ce que tu veux pas faire un
casting chinois où je vivais aux états
unis et je dis je connaissais la mission
aux états unis chez normand en général
en france air mec français ça me va pas
du tout et puis j'étais aux états unis
j'étais très très bien et puis
finalement je me suis laissé tenté j'ai
fait trois fiches à remplir
je sais même pas comment ils ont réussi
à comprendre ce que j'avais noté sur la
fiche et m'étais tellement j'en avais
hockey un peu rien à fiche rien à [ __ ]
quoi donc j'ai écrit comme ça et
finalement des contributions s'est
terminée est ce que tu t'es tu es déçu
tu étais triste ou pas du tout utilisé
reprendre une vie normale
tétine ans j'étais pas triste non
j'étais patrice que ça s'arrête on a
tous espéré qui est deuxième
oui on n'avait pas eu parce que c'était
un truc de prod etc mais triste annonce
qu'après j'ai eu plein plein d'émissions
plein d'autres émissions j'en ai fait
que avec loana sur sortez moi de là il
ya eu
il ya eu sur ab sur nt1 il a plutôt bien
t'as plus du tout envie de faire ça tu
es heureux moi je suis super ok il ya eu
une petite l'attend je travaille pour un
créateur d'accord s'appelle et voir à
chaud avec qui je travaillais déjà avant
de faire cuire d'accord et puis puis on
s'est retrouvé à traction cuvée des mois
dénonce alors moi je suis pas dans la
création ça je laisse ce travail à
édouard oui je ne connais même pas
dessiner un truc de bazus absolument pas
le faire mais moi je m'occupe de vendre
les collections d'accord les boutiques
toutes les boutiques à l'étranger en
tout cas et ça nous ont fait très
plaisir oui
[Applaudissements]